welcome to CBS this morning we begin in
Ohio the weather is so not good they're
relentless
severe weather pattern brought violent
tornadoes to Ohio and Indiana overnight
the rapid-fire line of twisters caused
devastating damage in southwestern Ohio
debris was so bad in one area that crews
actually had to use snowplows
yes snow plows to clear interstate 75
this morning officials say one person
was killed when a car was thrown on top
of him this heartbreaking image shows
other people walking through the debris
chief weather caster Lonnie Quinn of our
New York station that's wcbs-tv is
watching the conditions there a violent
tornado tore through Salina under the
cover of darkness this is exactly where
it came through it most people woken by
the storm emerged outside to find their
entire neighborhood nearly demolished
witnesses say the sounds of the tornado
were deafening as it destroyed houses
tossed cars and scattered debris all
across the streets boom everything just
started crashing around us this family
says the home they lived in for decades
is now gone I was a little surprised I
was waiting to hear the train but no
train came Celina Mayor Jeffery hazel I
was very pleased to find out how many
people actually immediately went to a
basement an area of safety about 55
miles southeast another tornado touched
down in Dayton just after 11 p.m. is
gone the tornado does NRL's
several houses were destroyed
the first responders are trying to break
down doors of damaged homes to check for
anyone trapped inside a quick flash of
lightning illuminated the massive
twister Oh showing it hovering in the
darkness many caught in the terrifying
path of the tornado say they are
grateful given what could have been I'm
laying there shaking my heads up against
the wall in the wall shaking back and
forth last about I'd say 10 to 15
seconds scariest 15 seconds of my life
we're lucky we're lucky to be here
tornadoes also left a trail of
destruction across central Indiana much
of the Midwest is at a risk for more
severe weather today